my name is Coriana buyer and I'm a
junior economics major in mathematics
minor here at Hillsdale College I'm also
a proud member of Chi Omega women's
fraternity the charger cheerleading team
and the Hillsdale College tower dancers
is with great pleasure that I introduce
William Walton tonight William Moulton
is the managing partner of Rappahannock
ventures rush river entertainment and
the forged Studios he is also vice
president of the council for national
policy and a senior fellow at the
Discovery Institute Center on wealth
poverty and morality a former director
of the US Chamber of Commerce mr. Walton
earned his BS and MBA at Indiana
University he has served as chairman of
the board and CEO of Allied Capital
Corporation and also as managing
director of Butler Capital Corporation
he serves on several boards of directors
including the Heritage Foundation the
media Research Center and for America
mr. Walton is a trustee for the National
Gallery of Art and the president of the
Washington Virginia Volunteer Fire and
Rescue Company ladies and gentlemen
please welcome me in introducing William
Walton
well thank you that was that was very
kind boy am I happy to be at Hillsdale
I've heard about Hillsdale I guess we've
all heard about Hillsdale through rush
rushes show but standing here in front
of this group is an incredible honor I
talked with some people at dinner
tonight that I think knew more about
what I'm going to talk about than I do
so when we get to the Q&A I'm I'm
expecting a challenging time we've got a
debate coming up at 9 o'clock tonight
and Trump has gotten to me so we're
gonna try to keep the remarks relatively
short so we can get to Q&A and so let's
talk about cronyism as Coriana mentioned
I've spent most of my current Wall
Street and in business as new CEO of a
New York Stock Exchange company allied
capital basically a publicly traded
private equity firm highly regulated by
the SEC I live our headquarters were
just three blocks from the White House I
was also in the board of the Financial
Services Roundtable which is 100 largest
financial services company so in my
experience I've been both in the arena
in the in the capital markets but also
have had a first sort of front row seat
to the comings and goings in Washington
and for reasons which will be clear
later I I consider myself a recovering
member of the US Chamber of Commerce so
well well anyway this is not all about
the chamber but this bears on their work
you know as I prepared this talk I
started out not wanting to tell a story
of good and evil greedy capitalists
intensive and coercive what regulators
venal politicians K Street lobbyists
versus the rest of us and then you know
sort of the talk radio version of
cronyism
and I didn't think it was that simple
but after digging into this issue I
think it is
we have a massive growing problem in
America it's a moral issue it explains
why economic growth is anemic and it's a
bipartisan issue the problem is that the
size and scope of the federal government
is such that's impossible to tell where
business ends and government starts the
federal budget now is four trillion
dollars federal regulatory cost add up
to another 1.7 trillion dollar burden
the economy there 87,000 new federal
rules that have been issued since 1993
and so business has a lot of interest in
stake and what goes on in Washington
business is complain about regulation
and intrusive coercive government but
when they lobby for maintaining and
increasing subsidies and mandates at the
expense of taxpayers and consumers they
threaten public support for business and
free markets the growing ancestress
relationship between business and
government in America is a destructive
force undermining not just our economy
in our political system but the
foundations of our culture we have a
term for this kind of collusion between
business and government it used to be
called rent seeking now we call it
cronyism regulation and are incredibly
complex tax code are big drags on
business and economic growth they're
also the main vehicles and the means to
suppress competition and keep new
entrants out I vastly oversimplify but I
think there are essentially two ways to
for a business to make money one way is
in the market competing for customers
and a free system of voluntary exchange
and the other way is petitioning the
government for a special privilege
cronyism such as subsidies for sugar or
crops product for mandates for products
like ethanol other special privileges
and the list is long grants loans tax
credits favorable regulations bailouts
loan guarantees targeted tax breaks no
bid contracts you know government's also
grant monopoly status
barriers to entry and protection from
foreign competition I mean it feels sort
of like we've got Louis the Louie the
fourteenth as as our King here less
obvious but also a form of cronyism or
occupational licenses teachers
certification and school accreditation I
believe the right way to engage in
economics is what economists call
voluntary exchange voluntary changed its
pros lives and makes the economy grow
and causes free markets to produce the
great results they have in contrast to
coercion and cronyism voluntary exchange
is the process where people willingly
trade one item for another making both
better off as a result the emphasis here
is unwillingly Apple has an iPad for
sale for five hundred dollars you give
them five hundred dollars they say the
iPad this is a voluntary exchange where
both participants believe they're better
off after the trade this lies at the
heart of free enterprise market
efficiency and act and entrepreneurship
individuals cooperate with each other
reach agreements trade and a network of
relationship that emerges revolves out
of this trading process is called the
market millions of voluntary exchanges
every day make the world better off they
have the great virtue of being both
moral and promoting economic growth by
contrast taxes government statutes and
regulations mandate in voluntary
exchanges they rely on coercion a harsh
word to try this out don't pay your
taxes see you see who shows up to seize
your assets and or put you in jail
and it's in it's voluntary exchange that
is most under the threat from the
government and it's crony partners
whether it's the minimum wage EPA
regulations abortion insurance mandates
for small business licensing or
entrepreneurial freedoms are being
eroded increasingly we were being told
for example what we can sell to whom we
can
and what wages and benefits we must
provide this is an increasingly
poisonous toxic mix for entrepreneurship
innovation economic freedom and growth
it also aids and abets and transcends
entrenched incumbents in the time we
have here tonight I can only give an
overview and a few examples of what I
what I mean if you want a deep dive into
the product of Cromie ism and I might
interject you I thought I was going to
be talking to all college students
tonight so those are you who or not I've
got some reading assignments for you as
well you know the first book I think is
one of the essential books for reading
it's by man Carlson it's the rise in
decline of nations which explains
paradoxically the longer a society
enjoys political stability it's more
likely to develop powerful special
interest lobbies that in turn make it
less efficient economically it's the
problem of factions that our founders
knew about we're groups with
concentrated interest form factions at
the expense of the rest of society he
called it and this is a $5 word
advanced institutional sclerosis the
second book and it might be obvious I've
actually read these books the second
book by Charles Mary of the American
Enterprise Institute where I was a
trustee it's called by the people it
provides an excellent history an
analysis of the end of what he calls the
American project the founding principle
of America that people can be left as
free individuals families and
communities so live their lives as long
as they see fit as long as they Accord
the same freedom to everyone else with
such government safeguarding a peaceful
setting for those endeavors but
otherwise standing aside he concludes
that the normal political process will
not restore us to a nation devoted
lemmon government and economic and
religious freedom he actually calls
cronyism corruption
the third book I want to recommend is by
George Gilder he's the founder of
Discovery Institute where I serve as a
fellow it's called knowledge and power
and this is a much more optimistic book
it shows us that economic growth is
driven by sudden unexpected
revolutionary innovations driven by
entrepreneurs he described it left to
its own devices an entrepreneurial
economy will rescue itself while massive
government interventions only disrupt
the information loop between the market
and entrepreneurs
he says everything useful or interesting
depends on agents of change called
entrepreneurs capitalism is not simply
an information an incentive system but
an information system and wealth expands
through learning and discovery
regulation and tax systems that seek to
command and control the economy distort
the market signals that innovation
requires any system that protects old
ways of doing things
cronyism stifle innovation and growth
his optimistic message though is that an
economic system can revive itself as
quickly as minds and policies can change
this talk is titled the problem of crony
capitalism today I don't believe that
American politicians bureaucrats and
businesses today are more venal or
dishonest than politician or businessman
of the past there has forever and always
will bit and always will be cronyism
people seeking special favors from
government what's changed is the scope
and reach of the federal government it's
dramatically expanded before the 1930s
corporate court interpretations and the
general consensus in America was that
the Constitution severely restricted the
power of the federal government then a
constitutional revolution occurred from
1937 to 1942 it dramatically expanded
the federal government powers
there's not enough time to get into the
details but essentially there are three
reads three Supreme Court rulings that
changed everything
the first allowed Congress to delegate
its powers to federal agencies the
second gutted the commerce clause giving
the federal government to power over
regulating virtually all manufacturing
and agriculture in the United States
federal judge Alec Kaczynski calls this
hey you can do anything you feel like
Clause the third ruling declaring Social
Security constitutional reinterpreted
the general welfare clause to allow
Congress to spend money on virtually
anything fast forward to today
unfortunately believe there's a little
chance these rulings can be reversed as
charles murray observes to reverse any
of these rulings would mean about 90% of
everything the federal government does
is unconstitutional and that's just not
gonna happen before the New Deal in
1930s very few industries were affected
by what went on in Washington
only if you ran a railroad or a utility
and were looking for tariff protection
from foreign competition did you need to
think about dealing with the federal
government the New Deal assured in the
Civil Aeronautics Board and the FCC and
about a dozen other industry specific
agencies but if he weren't in those
industries not much changed and even by
1960 only a handful of corporations even
had a small office in Washington then
came Lyndon Johnson in the Great Society
and a great pouring of regulations from
Washington almost 30 pages were added to
the code of federal regulation by the
end of the 1960's the Civil Rights Act
of 1964 brought about unprecedented
federal oversight of employee hiring
firing and promotion but it was Richard
Nixon who truly brought us the
regulatory state from 1970 to 1974 16
new major regulatory agencies were
established including the EPA the OSHA
and the powers of the EEO
see were greatly expanded what made
these regulatory ages agencies different
was that they were given economy-wide
authority to regulate every business in
the country the number of pages in the
federal code of regulations had risen to
hunt nearly 175,000 by 2012 and on a
parallel path the federal tax code
became increasingly complex massively
intrusive with thousands reductions
incentives penalties and specialty
favors for virtually every industry in
America we now have a tax code that's
four million words long and how did
business respond they went to Washington
and by the end of the 70s most major
corporations and trade groups had set up
offices in DC and here's the key point
as the regulatory state has grown the
role of politicians and their staff has
changed and grown in power they've added
the role of liaison with the regulatory
agencies to the business of also of
working with legislation with enormous
power over the activities of the private
sector literally billions of dollars can
be at stake for an industry depending
what Washington does or doesn't do this
is the principal cause for the cash flow
of lobbying money going to K Street as
charles murray puts it corruption in the
political process varies directly with
the number and value of things that
politicians have to sell that value has
increased exponentially politics has now
become a way to get rich it's a seldom
Remarque fact of American politics the
people in the top leadership positions
and this is what I see timed day in and
day out in Washington senators cabinet
officers ranking members of the House of
Representatives Democrats and
Republicans alike with a life utterly
removed from the people they rule the
trappings of office include cars and
drivers private jets four-star
restaurants skyboxes all free
these people aren't carrying their own
luggage and Posca
most come to Washington filled with
ideals and plans for change then the
system corrupts them as a friend of mine
how Regnery whose publisher of the
American Spectator puts it they come to
clean up the cesspool in Washington then
they discover it's a hot tub a few years
ago in 2006 I had my first personal
direct experience with the lobbying
culture in Washington as well here I
learned that even politicians I believe
are among the good guys get captured by
how Congress works and how the special
interests work their agenda into
legislation as a CEO of a highly
regulated financial company I concluded
as many other CEOs do that I needed to
understand how the political process
worked and if nothing else to protect
our country's interest from harmful
regulation and legislation so we set up
a political action committee and I was
invited to a packed event sponsored by a
senator that I had great respect for I
still do he invited me down to a NASCAR
event and in Homestead Florida the
weekend event about 30 40 people
attending I'd never been to a Rascar
mascot race I saw the Michigan Speedway
here if you've never been to a NASCAR
race you've got to go it's the most
exciting thing anyway at the time the
transportation bill was in the works
it was a huge bill loaded with a pork
most of which wasn't about
transportation and the attendees it
turned out were mostly lobbyists I was
the only so-called civilian there whose
business wasn't lobbying and as the
weekend progressed my senator friends
sort of looked at me quizzically as if I
was supposed to come up and talk to him
about something and finally on Sunday we
were getting ready to leave he finally
asked he said so so what are you down
here for yeah well you know I'm down
here I want good judges less regulation
tax reform and he said he looked at me
he smiled he said you're new to
Washington aren't you
and he said everybody here has got
something in the transportation bill and
they did and they still do you know it
seems like every time Congress passes
one of these big new bills it's intended
to benefit incumbents big business
entrenched interests and ends up hurting
small business and consumers three bills
spring to mind
sarbanes-oxley dodd-frank dodd-frank the
Affordable Care Act also known as
Obamacare now Obamacare is an
interesting case it's principal
beneficiaries were to be the health
insurance Hospital and pharmaceutical
companies as well as some uninsured
people but as it turned out yes it
brought some people in an insurance
system but the expense of everyone else
and everyone else included and that
meant the pharmaceutical companies and
the hospitals and the insurance
companies which I think rue the day that
they've got behind this bill but people
that are not ruling the day or the
beneficiaries of dodd-frank dodd-frank
as you recollect we came up after 2008
it was supposed to be aimed at Wall
Street punishing evildoers and instead
it hit Main Street much harder community
financial financial institutions which
make the bulk of small business loans
are overwhelmed by the law's complexity
government figures indicate that the
country is losing on average one
community bank or credit union a day
compare this to the hundred new banks of
dinner the economy every year between
1990 and the financial crisis in 2008
from 2009 to 2013 and only three or four
new banks that have started it's
absolutely put a hold on bank bank
formation and some reason for the
decline I mentioned increased compliance
cost regulatory compliance cost for
example there's a small Bank United
Southern Bank in Kentucky about the same
size as it was in 2009 but had I had 15
back office worker to ensure compliance
with new federal regulations the Federal
Reserve Board I think you heard about
that this afternoon I mean they've had a
policy to manipulate money keep interest
rates at zero and the beneficiaries have
been
big banks and the small banks their net
interest margins have been been I won't
say crush but certainly squeezed and its
really it's hurt them on addition to
their up their compliance cost and the
really interesting number is it's going
to take over 24 million man-hours per
year or person hours to comply with the
rules imposed by dodd-frank it took only
20 million hours to build the Panama
Canal goldman sachs CEO lloyd blankfein
blank Fein frankly tells us that Goldman
is a big beneficiary of dodd-frank
he says the barriers to entry in the
banking business are higher than any
other time in modern history JP Morgan
CEO Jamie Dimon and I know these guys
has said the same thing explaining that
dodd-frank had created what Warren
Buffett calls an economic moat around
the big banks keeping competitors out
Tim Carney I think most you know writes
for The Washington Times he says
regulation that dodd-frank protects the
Giants because policy and politics and
lobbying are home games for them Goldman
is famously close with Washington and
the revolving door between Goldman and
its regulators is well trafficked more
regulation increases the value of
lobbyists and lawyers particularly the
lobbyists and lawyers who used to be law
makers or regulators for example he
calls Wauwatosa community bank can't
afford to hire many former members of
the House Financial Services Committee
that would be Mike what Mike Oxley for
those who want me to name names and this
is a big problem because in this big
problem for the economy and why the
economy is not growing looked at
something like the community banks which
represent the vast majority of banks and
are critical because they are likely to
make more small business loans than
anyone else
they hold 46% of loans to farms and
small businesses where they only hold
14% of total the industry banking assets
for rural communities small banks are
often the only letter lender since big
banks are closing branches here
sarbanes-oxley
for decades u.s. stock exchanges were
seen by companies around the world as
the most prestigious location to list
chairs but the number of listings in
u.s. in the u.s. peaked at eight
thousand eight hundred and eighty four
companies in 1997 it's now down to
roughly five thousand and it's
regulations such as sarbanes-oxley
section 404 reg FD that have had a
chilling effect in companies wishing to
go public in the US but a once again
sarbanes-oxley had little effect on the
big companies which could easily absorb
the extra burden of the regulation let
me give you example when a small company
or a growth company wants to go public
regulatory costs can be as much as four
or five million dollars a year from any
of these companies that's their profit
and so to go public kills their profit
and increases the amount of time they
need to spend complying with things and
they just don't go public CEOs of the
rate of emerging growth companies choose
instead to be acquired now why is this a
problem that's fine so far as growth
goes well you may have heard some terms
a few years ago called gazelles their
emergency and technology growth
companies and turns out big companies in
America don't create jobs their net
destroyers of jobs and all the job
creation comes not necessarily from
small business that comes from emerging
growth companies and as they grow and
innovate and expand they had they had
high paying jobs rapidly and it's those
kind of companies that have disappeared
from the IPO market and since 2008 o
meanwhile and this is interesting we've
only had a hundred and seventy seven
listings annually since 2008 in the US
the number of listings in China four
thousand so lobbying has evolved from
companies protecting themselves from
such things as tax increases and
regulations to using the political
process to help them become more
profitable the classic case is the
Medicare Modernization Act of 2003 which
measured in the Medicare drug benefits
for elders it's been estimated that the
pharmaceutical companies the lobbied for
this
spent about a hundred and thirty two
hundred and fifty million dollars it's a
lot of money but the benefits are that
the drug sales that they expect to reap
from this and last in the 10-year period
are roughly 200 billion dollars two
hundred billion dollars so you know many
many many times what they had to spend
to get the law enacted but for me the
classic case of General Electric we we
actually did a joint venture with
General Electric Capital there were good
guys but if you look at the company I've
there things that bothered me a great
deal last year's annual report GE
described itself as a new kind of
industrial company well that's that's
for sure
in the last decade GE spent well over
300 million dollars lobbying and Jeff
Immelt at CEO has visited the White
House over thirty three times since
Obama's become president so so why would
the business spend this kind of time and
money lobbying because it produces
results
General Electric paid no federal income
taxes from 2008 to 2012 and instead it
got it 3.1 billion dollar in refund
refund on 27 point five billion dollars
in profits during this period it's
received over two billion in federal
loan guarantees for wind and solar
projects it was a big recipient of the
bank bank bailout tarp money
notwithstanding the fact that GE Capital
is not a bank it was paid subsidies of
one hundred and thirty two million for a
lithium battery company that ended up in
bankruptcy and of course one of the most
effective ways to lobby is to wrap your
special interest in a cloak of some
public good and in the in the name of
protecting the environment ge was one of
the principal advocates of energy
legislation that effectively outlawed
the incandescent bulb replaced of course
with the LED bulb what what this bought
GE was that was able to get out a low
margin unprofitable incandescent bulb
business and into the much more high
margin profitable LED business before
the legislation
consumers balked at the higher prices
for led with the law were now all forced
to pay up in another loudly proclaim
show of giving back GE donated 30
million dollars to New York City Schools
11 million went to Charlie Rangel's
district somebody knows this punchline
anyway at the time Charlie was chairman
of the House Ways and Means Committee
overseeing what else corporate taxes
what a coincidence
on the Charlie Rose show MML praised the
communist government of China saying
state-run communists may not be your cup
of tea but their government works he
also told shareholders that in a reset
economy the government we a regulator
but also an industry and policy champion
a financier and a key partner the
interaction between government and
business will change forever
yes ge is a new kind of industrial
company so are there solutions to the
pervasive and growing problem of
cronyism if so I believe they need to be
big ones radical ones tinkering with
things like term limits rudolph
revolving door lobbying campaign finance
reform
I don't believe are likely to change
much so long as trillions of dollars are
at stake for people to do lobby or
engage in cronyism main core Elson main
core Olson believed there's only one way
to cure advanced institutional sclerosis
be utterly defeated in a world war his
examples Japan and Germany they were
forced to start over after World War two
so they got rid of all the institutional
barriers to growth and in fact had
growth economies through the 50s and 60s
charles murray advocates massive civil
disobedience although as somebody
pointed out tonight it's a rather
civilized form of justice civil
disobedience where lawsuits will be
underwritten by privately funded
multi-billion dollar defense funds that
would sue government and cronyism George
will argue that we need a zero-based the
budget every year or three zero basement
every agency's budget on a three-year
cycle so that they have to come back
every three years and show that they're
doing something worthwhile and if you
don't think this is feasible he points
out out
New Zealand did it after World War Two
and turned their beef industry or their
their cattle industry into a world
leader by basically sunsetting the
regulator's for the industry he'd also
sunset all regulations after after ten
years I would start with getting rid of
the tax code the income tax code and
replacing with a fat flat tax or fair
tax that would eliminate tax code
cronyism and it would ignite the economy
in a way that I we just wouldn't believe
4% growth would be low whatever we do
and I'm not advocating being heavily
defeated in a world war we need to think
big we need act now and I'm hoping some
Hillsdale graduates will lead the charge
thank you
okay well I hope I hope I was able to
stimulate some questions or some
challenges or some other thoughts a lot
of smart people here quick question
what's happened to the US Department of
Chamber are the Chamber of Commerce I've
got a story I joined because I thought
they're doing some good things with the
capital markets and they've got a
litigation fund aimed at the trial you
know trial lawyers but they put me in
their cap on their PAC committee and I
went to a PAC meeting this was in 2010
and it was a summer of 2010 and we had
the makings of a wave election so the
Republicans could take back the house
and I went to this meeting and again I'm
I'm a civilian in these meetings I'm not
a professional lobbyist and so I was in
there and we're going down the list of
congressional candidates that they
wanted to support in this cycle and I'm
walking in thinking this is a slam dunk
we've got to support every Republican in
the race because we want to eliminate
two words from the vocabulary speaker
Pelosi and so about 45 minutes into the
meeting what we've got what's been
happening we going down this list of
candidates and they're giving money to
everybody in the most promiscuous way
they're giving money to Democrats that
have like a you know they have
scorecards and they rank only 25 out of
100 on the Chamber's scorecard and
Republicans that didn't do that much
better and I then sort of stopped the
meeting and I said I think we're going
at this the wrong way we need to support
every Republican because we can't we
can't have Pelosi as leader we've got to
get a majority and boy the outrage that
caused I mean the other people in the
room they just said look we've got to
work with these people you know they're
viable we got to do stuff we can't take
full position if we're going to be
effective and I I think I was on the
board for another few months I mean it
just it just and you know that's the
issue I mean people I think people may
come to Washington with principles but
they certainly don't keep them very long
because the system doesn't really reward
principled behavior I mean it even
happens to the new congressmen that come
into town I mean they we've talked with
a lot of them the guy Meadows who went
through hell the summer they cut you out
of key meetings they take your
legislation they basically ostracize you
and they tell you you know if you want
to help if you want a committee or if
you want to build past you've got to
learn how to play the game and play
along and so within even even ferocious
freshman congressman that came in in
2010 in 2014 our you know the they're
taught how to play the game
the way the leader wanted him to play
hopefully Ryan will be better but the
chamber they're not they're not a force
for a positive change yeah back there
enough if you go back to Enron was Enron
reverse crony capitalism because I was
thinking back to this past week where of
the Attorney General of New York decided
to reco Exxon as misrepresenting their
liabilities under global warming to the
stockholders but Enron was an example of
a country company that had paid off
every politician in the country so how
did Enron end up like Enron and is what
is happening in New York to Exxon part
of crony capitalism or is it the old
Roman principle where the emperor
condemns a wealthy person has a traitor
and then kills him and then confiscates
all his property
oh let's let's take Enron first Enron
was a company they had no cashflow and
they they had accounting but cheap
treatment that made it look like they're
profitable but if you if you looked at
their balance sheet they were they had
they had no cashflow and no ability to
survive and they kept the plates
spinning and I think when somebody said
the infrared no close it collapse B and
they didn't have that you couldn't you
couldn't have enough friends to save
Enron it was just such a catastrophe
Exxon I don't know there probably other
people opinions here I think Exxon has
been on the wrong side of some things
it's a little more conservative than
shell and and you know the thing about
regulators and I had to deal with them a
lot is that they're vindictive people
they're individuals you know the regular
charles murray makes his point his book
I mean you think of these regulatory
monoliths and this agency and that
agency and practice you're only dealing
with two or three or four people lawyers
whatever they are that get a get an
agenda and then they they work the
agenda and you hear well the EPA is
coming after them or the Department of
Labor things like that it's usually a
handful of people that are largely
unsupervised that do a lot of this so
there may be personal things going on
there that I don't know about I don't
know do you have a follow-up on that I'd
love to hear what you think except for
the senator Parker anyway another
question yeah
I was wondering what your thoughts were
around the h-1b visas regarding crony
capitalism whereby they're bringing
skilled and computer trained individuals
from countries like India and kicking
out highly trained computer American
people in this country obviously Disney
as an example some of the high tech
companies out in California and it's
even from what I miss a lot to talk
radio Laura Ingraham is pointing out
it's going to drop down to where your
only local mechanic may be able to pass
the requirements to come in here and
kick American workers are their jobs at
lower wages in general for the total
American economy based on these h-1b
visas are you into that $1 following the
really strong impact especially in
Silicon Valley and Disney's another
example and other places throughout are
you saying we ought to be hiring
Americans only yeah well yeah I mean
we've got trained people who are that
they're required to train these people
from India and what they do
they've got computer science degrees for
example and if they don't train them
they're kicked out right now after
they're done training they get their
severance and their goodbye pay well i'm
thinking in coal-burning mark levin have
got I mean I used to be a free trader
and I think we've been laterally
disarmed and I think that's one of the
reasons Trump has become popular as he's
saying things that are true about losing
jobs and there are plenty of Engineers
in America that could be hired and I'm
not quite sure what the you know you get
the people in Silicon Valley and there
get their own little culture or they
want to bring people in that are just
like them and they forget the rest of
America and I think no I don't think we
should do that
the story just told seems to come
straight out of Atlas Shrugged by higher
end have you ever read that book I think
I live that book and if you haven't if
you haven't you shoot we all shoot yeah
many times over well I think we've who
was a who's the who's the evil guy at
Ellsworth Toohey and Atlas Shrugged
anyway he was The Fountainhead the
estate of similar Kevin at what feels
like that I mean the regulators and and
the cronies and the I guess The
Fountainhead springs to mind more I
actually read the whole fountain that I
never quite finished Atlas Shrugged it
does feel like that I mean it and that's
why I summarized with radical solutions
I think I think a litigation fund or you
know we've Colin Hanna from lettering
and ring let freedom ring has got a
something he's trying to push called
sunset the tax code the thing we're
worried about is if we push to get rid
of the tax code we'd end up with a fight
over there's a flat tax or fair tax or
value-add tax and we would agree to
sunset the tax code at date certain say
2018-2019 and then engage in a debate
public policy debate about what we want
to replace it with because they're good
arguments on both sides but the four
million words the Internal Revenue Code
is is something we've got to do
something about and I'd add with the
with the Internal Revenue Code I think
we can win on this because it's a
fairness issue even though 47% of
Americans supposedly aren't paying
income taxes they do have to deal with
the tax code and they also feel that the
tax code is riven with special interest
so that their neighbors getting a better
deal and they are and everybody feels
it's unfair
and even people getting earned income
tax credits that were getting paid from
the Internal Revenue Service are getting
put through hoops and so nobody likes it
it's a winning political issue and I
think I think that's one area where we
could really unite people maybe on both
sides of both sides of the argument to
do something about that and thank you
very much for your talk
you know Adam Smith opined that the real
threat to capitalism was capitalists who
would try to use their money to limit
competition
Schumpeter thought that capitalism would
succumb to its own success
my question is relative to the bailout
of AIG Henry Paulson obviously from
Goldman and we all know that Washington
DC's become a revolving door for goldman
sachs executives he let Lehman go under
but he bailed at AIG which most of us
think was a stealth bailout of Societe
Generale and Goldman because of the
derivative exposure that Goldman had
that AIG had supposedly backed and
underwritten blank fine says that well
they had it cross-collateralized so what
did he big deal but my question to you
is do you think that Henry Paulson being
a Goldman X Goldman executive had
anything to do with the bailout of AIG
and would you consider this crony
capitalism yes to both
you know I had a very I mentioned I was
on the board of the Financial Services
Roundtable and that was a very
interesting place because my company's
market cap was about 6 billion and
everybody else's was about 6 trillion
and you know suppose I was in the
meetings with Jamie Dimon and all these
people and I remember when Paulson came
in to meet with us in September of 2008
he came with it came to visit with us
two or three times he was a Hulk he was
human there was no you know he doesn't
drink but I would have thought the guy
was just you know there's nothing
there's no fumes and I thought gee this
is the guy who's making policy for
America
and do I think their personal agenda is
that these guys have yeah they didn't
like Dick Fuld I used to work at Lehman
Brothers Kuhn Loeb and you know Lehman
Brothers made itself very unpopular we
were surprised when Bear Stearns got
bailed out because Bear Stearns wouldn't
participate in some of the things that
they wanted me to be and I do think did
anybody read that book about the hedge
fund too big was the hedge fund that the
big no anyway there's a there's a famous
hedge fund that collapsed and I can't
remember 10 years ago 15 years ago long
term capital and you know they had their
book and they read the golden was hired
to bail him out and instead of bailing
him out they had some guy with the
computer finding out what all their
positions were and so golden was trading
against their own client so uh any of
you are planning to go to work for
goldman sachs see me after the after the
talk you don't want to let him know you
know me yeah oh yes yeah would you care
to comment on what the council for
national policy is doing or could be
doing or should be doing to restore the
American dream
well we're our next meeting and I invite
you all to come we're calling it
preserving a protecting civil society
and what we believe is that the family
marriage Boy Scouts police military is
all being deconstructed by the left and
we've got to develop we go talk of a
common voice on that we've also ramped
up our our recruiting efforts we want to
bring in more of the people who go to
things like the Coke seminars where we
want to get them directly involved with
people involved doing doing things in a
cultural area but you know the thing
we've got to do in the thing I'm
interested in trying to help is we need
to get more wood behind the tip of the
sphere because council national policy
we've got four four hundred members are
all doing amazing things but each one of
them individually is under-resourced
and if I could do anything one any one
thing to help it would be try to bring
more capital to bear on the on the
organization's I might really make a
difference so but but council the
national policy I don't you all know it
you probably haven't heard of it was
formed in 1981 Ronald Reagan asked this
group of people to form an Eden I can't
remember the founders were but it was a
very illustrious group of people and
they acted kind of as a kitchen cabinet
outside the government to help move
things along and policy matters in both
national defense social issues and
economic issues and we're now ramping
that back up to see if we can't make a
difference in the policy debate I thanks
so much for your talk you mentioned
earlier how a lot of smaller emerging
emerging businesses are foregoing
launching an IPO and going public to
rather to be acquired by a bigger
company so my question is in the modern
technological market there's a lot of
tech startups today that would rather be
bought out by bigger companies like
Facebook or Google rather than launch an
IPO do you think that's negative for to
the job market as well and if so how
would you correct a problem like that
well for years what happened in the
technology business venture capital we
all everybody wanted to go public it was
it was a badge of honor you get your
picture on one of the ink magazine or
something like that and being public and
being a CEO of a public company put you
in a superstar status you know how long
ago was that and then after the
regulatory changes that dodd-frank
brought about and a lot of other things
that have happened it's become
increasingly unattractive to be public
and unless you're really a big company
that can afford all the compliance cost
you your incredibly financially burden
but more than adds the bigger problem is
this I remember one of the board
meetings I was in where I was with my
board and and we'd had a meeting as a
three-hour meeting and we were finishing
the meeting and I said I'm afraid we're
gonna have to ruin a perfect meeting
they kind of looked at me and they said
I said well look we've covered on it
we've covered compliance we've covered
the SEC we've covered you know our
employee policies we're now going to
have to talk about the business and
that's the issue when you're in that
environment there's so many other things
that are not related to creating a great
product or service or building your team
that you've just don't the public
company is not conducive to that and so
I think yeah it's a big problem and it's
a big problem specifically with jobs
because the companies that were going
public in the in the 80s and 90s they
were growing like a weed and they were
innovating and they're adding employees
and they're paying them a lot and and I
don't remember the statistics Kauffman
Institute and Kansas I think has come up
with the numbers but something like 90%
of all the jobs are created during that
period were created by you know 500
companies and that's just a fact and
we'd not seen that now and I would say
that's one of the reasons we're not
seeing the growth
I mean you are not seeing the creation
of good jobs John Chambers I went to
business school with ended up running
Cisco great guy great entrepreneur great
CEO but his business model was if there
was a good company that could help Cisco
they'd buy the company they'd get the
technology they get the brand name and
then they didn't need the people and so
you're you know yeah so it's a big issue
and I would lay it back to the
regulations that came out that made an
unattractive to be public just like to
thank you for speaking tonight you
mentioned toward the end of your speech
the idea of sun setting regulation every
few years you gave the example of New
Zealand and the cattle industry there is
one example that was successful I'm not
really familiar with it but my initial
instinct would be that this would
increase the incentive for companies and
corporations to lobby bringing
regulation up every couple years for
discussion it seems like that could have
harmful impacts in the economy as far as
the allocation of capital spent on
lobbying rather than productive means
could use comment on that you're
probably right I mean I you know the
thing that we know about all these laws
are all these changes of Washington
anything you do now as I hope I conveyed
the government and the business
community are so interconnected and
every industry has its regulator or
whatever like that any change like that
is going to cause everybody to try to
come to Washington and you know get an
outcome that benefits them so you may be
right but I think you know I'd want to
I'd want to get in a room with a lot of
smart people to figure out whether we
could pull Kraft something that wouldn't
have that unintended consequence you
know remember we've got a constitution I
think it says something about being
petitioned the government
I mean lobbying abstractly something we
ought to be able to do it's just in
practice because of the growth of the
government that it's become so odious
hi I just wondering if you've read
Donald Trump's tax plan and if you have
do you think it'll be as bad for the
debt as a lot of the experts are saying
it will be I don't think I'd really call
it a plan yeah it I know I have not
studied his plan let's plan I really
liked even though he's not my candidate
was Marco Rubio's plan that was written
by art Laffer and Steve Moore and Larry
Kudlow and it it eliminates the code
altogether starts over and puts it puts
a flat tax on personal income and it's
got kind of a value-added VAT tax for
corporations and it's great for
corporations would rapidly increase the
incentives to invest even though it
actually raises the taxes on
corporations so I'm with Donald we hope
you know I asked Donald a question we
heard a meeting and I was I was asked
Donald Donald income inequalities risen
dramatically in the last five years and
while the middle class is really
struggling can you given your wealth
explain why that happened and he would
let me finish the question because he
wanted to get on to something else and I
gave him the answer I said the reason
income inequality has become an issue is
that the federal reserve reserve
monetary policies caused asset prices to
go way up which has benefited wealthy
people but it hasn't helped anybody else
in the country and some incomes are
stagnant people aren't in the stock
market or seeing their their asset
values flat or down so I don't know I
hope I didn't answer your question the
right way
we have time for one more question okay
yeah Duyvil wants us to pay attention I
was just wondering if you could comment
on I have been told by many intelligent
people on both sides of the aisle that
the only way anything will ever get
fixed is revolution given that business
and government is so interconnected they
might as well be symbiotic do you think
that is true that the only way to solve
anything these days is start over and
yeah short of being massively defeated
in a world war basically I've been told
many times that basically Texas needs to
secede for anything to get done well I
don't know that's a revolution but I you
know what is it anything that can't
continue forever won't and you know you
run the math on our deficits and you run
the math on the growth and the bad stuff
that we all worry about and I don't
think it continued forever but I don't
know what the catalyst would be to
unwind that and you get something like
that you can have with a really bad
outcome
you know French Revolution Russian
Revolution that didn't turn out so well
so you know the revolutions get captured
by bad people yes my wife
oh yeah my Sara points out to me Sara
points me I really think we're not
conservative I think we're the
counter-revolution and that we
counterculture and I've know Jenny Beth
Martin who's chairman of the Tea Party
Patriots you're CEO the Tea Party
Patriots and they're uh their
headquarters is in Woodstock Georgia and
I said to Jenny Beth I said Jenny Beth
you really had to use that Woodstock in
your brand because you're the
counterculture now and the people are at
the other Woodstock are all working for
the justice department trying to put us
in jail thank you very much